i'm rich [ __ ]
[ __ ] your question
[Music]
this is uh donna rollins and i'm here to
answer the [ __ ] ass internet who would
be the world's most dominant one-on-one
basketball player if everyone was forced
to play naked it would be
bobby lee
[Laughter]
for so many reasons
like it's not gonna be enough of me
what's that [ __ ] name y'all me
yeah i'm just saying i know that sounds
racist but it's true how many rats would
it take to overwhelm and kill you in a
fight
first off it wouldn't take no reps
because snitches get stitches
[ __ ]
you rap [ __ ] die
all right boy i love talking [ __ ] to the
enemy first i want to say you know what
you [ __ ] listen to listen to
this right now [ __ ] you
because no matter if i get this right or
wrong you're going to say something
you're going to say my audio was [ __ ]
up
you was like yeah
he ran from so-and-so and so-and-so
podcast so this is [ __ ] the internet can
i change your name yeah [ __ ] the
internet and your [ __ ] ask questions
okay would you rather have free
strippers for life or free pizza for
life damn that's a tough one i want to
have free pizza man yeah you know why
cause those tripping [ __ ] lied to you
son
oh my god that's the biggest thing i've
ever had at least a pizza would tell you
the truth and the pizza would tell you
that you need to stop smoking that weed
[ __ ] would you rather have a
chick with a great ass butt a great ass
but sideburns or a chick with great tits
but then both of these are she [ __ ]
[Music]
both of these
i mean i'm saying [ __ ] you what but
this is a trick question i just
[Music]
i don't know what to say
this is this is a chicks a dick's
question so next question son
that was a trick question if you had to
have a theme song play it every time you
arrived somewhere what would it be
figuring my life right now just in a
moment right now it would probably have
to be
this [ __ ] got me paying her it paying
for [ __ ] that was my theme song
no i'm not going through anything but
i'm prepared for the worst
[Laughter]
would you rather wake up to a blow oh
yes okay let me see part two would you
rather wake up to a [ __ ] or a hundred
under your pillow every a pillowcase
every morning whoa for the rest of your
life yeah hundred dollars yeah yo man
i'm always got my dick sucked enough man
that [ __ ] don't impress me and if i get
1000 of my pillow every day for the rest
of my life i could go pay for the blow
job with no spiritual or mental
connection boom you got to think
if your mom and your girlfriend switch
bodies and [ __ ] that
[ __ ] out of here
[ __ ] i ain't even read part of that [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of here man we got two more of
these man you getting personal now son
that was a dirty one you read that he
looked me right my face like we'll find
out you accept a million dollars to be
deported from the u.s
you can never come back but you get to
take one person
no
i got a million dollars now i'm rich
[ __ ]
[ __ ] your question
we're at 94 000 subscribers on kfc radio
the youtube channel i need to have it
hit six figures i need a hundred
thousand for 2022. let's make it happen
when we hit 100k we'll give you all
sorts of content we're going to deliver
on everything we've been promising so
please just subscribe all you got to do
is log in with your gmail click
subscribe whether or not you actually
even use youtube doesn't [ __ ] matter
all it does is help us so take your
gmail log in click subscribe and help us
out